tengo una pequeña simulación por aquí
que nos ahorrará mucho tiempo ya que
hace la selección aleatoria por nosotros
y me deja empezar con cuatro blancas y
dos negras vamos a hacer que la
computadora haga muchas selecciones para
nosotros entonces esto es cada selección
que la computadora hace lo equivalente a
seleccionar aleatoriamente una canica
revolver y elegir al azar una de ellas y
podemos ver como el porcentaje de las
blancas se acerca mucho al porcentaje
real o deberíamos decir a la razón de
blancas a negras de 4 a 2 me parece que
te creo ahora porque al principio
observamos mucha variación cierto de
esta gráfica sobre el tiempo y ahora
está casi plana en definitiva parece que
convergen en la proporción real y una
vez más hay una cierta probabilidad de
que esto no suceda así podremos tener
una de esas veces en un cuatrillón no sé
dónde eso lo elegimos una canica blanca
en cada selección
pero al final esto es consistente con la
intuición de que entre más intentos se
hagan la probabilidad de tener una
desviación significativa de la
proporción real disminuye